the studio is in perfect right now and
it gets so hot in here during the day I
tried to shoot this video two times and
I got way too sweaty so now I'm filming
it at night but I'm still doing it also
they're like moths and slides in here
except accidentally left the door open
and they were attracted to the light so
in an earlier video I talked about how
willpower is a finite resource that
depletes throughout the day with every
decision that you make and when you fall
asleep at night that willpower
replenishes back to max level but what
about increasing that maximum is it
possible to upgrade the amount of
willpower you have in general
neurologists and behavior psychologists
generally understand willpower is
something that can be strengthened
through practice which can help combat
things like procrastination for example
when we procrastinate the things that
we're doing to procrastinate are
obviously more exciting or more
stimulating than that thing that we're
avoiding unfortunately this is mostly
inescapable procrastination wouldn't
exist if doing super hard work was
really fun thankfully though you can
combat this phenomenon with willpower
which might be disappointing to you if
you're looking for some type of brain
Hat but really plain old fashioned
willpower is super helpful problem is a
lot of people these days don't seem to
have much of it and don't really know
how to improve it either let's talk
about one of the greatest ways to
strengthen overall willpower and
potentially make the quality of your
life better in general and that is by
regularly practicing acts of self-denial
self-denial is the willingness to forego
personal pleasures in the pursuit of the
increased good of another doing what I
just read can be easy as not taking the
last cookie from the cookie jar
even if you think you really deserve it
and there's no real reason not to we're
only watching one episode of your
favorite Netflix show even when Netflix
starts Auto cueing the next one
diabolically like it does so there you
go just do that every day and your
willpower will increase
you're probably not satisfied with that
though one of the most popular and
well-known scientific experiments are
psychological is there really a fly in
my face one of the most and that is the
famous marshmallow experiment this took
place in the 1960s so in the marshmallow
experiment psychologist Walter Mischel
sat a bunch of elementary schoolchildren
down one by one and offered them the
choice of one marshmallow now
or if they could wait five minutes
they'd get two marshmallows so after
this happened Michelle sort of followed
these children's all the way these
children's Walter Mischel sort of
tracked the performance and overall life
quality of these children as they became
adults and he found out that the ones
that were able to resist temptation
earlier on in life found greater success
academically career-wise and they even
had lower rates of marital separation
this study suggests that self-denial
directly translates into success in
other areas of life another study shows
that self-denial not only translates
into success in other areas of life but
could also have an impact on overall
happiness according to a 2013 paper
published in social psychological and
personality science I had to do that
this study took place at the University
of British Columbia and involves 55
participants so to simplify things there
were three groups in the study group one
was given a bunch of chocolate and told
not to eat it fruit two was just told
nothing and group three was given a
bunch of chocolate and told to eat as
much as they comfortably could over the
next week one week later all three
groups came back ate a piece of
chocolate and then reported on their
feelings of overall happiness
unsurprisingly group three who binge
soxhlet all week long were the least
happy about eating that piece of
chocolate
whereas Group one who couldn't eat
chocolate that whole time were the most
happy it may not be surprising that
self-denial makes people long for the
thing they can't have yet the chocolate
study shows that people who practice
self-denial are actually happier in the
end because they savor more so in
societies where there's abundance
overall happiness and improved
well-being are not a guarantee sometimes
discipline saying no to the thing that's
right in front of you even when there's
no real reason why you can't have it
leads to greater happiness and success
in your life in the end if you liked
this video be sure to hit that like
button if you like these videos in
general hit that subscribe button if you
haven't already you want to say
something to me either positive or
negative leave it in the comment section
below I don't really like a ton of
negativity so I'll probably delete your
negative comments but you might as well
give it a shot anyways